hey what's up mkbhd here and i've been
using ipad os 16 on the new ipad pro for
a little while and one of the biggest
new features on it is called stage
manager and i have a theory about it
now a lot of ipad power users like
myself have been excited for this
feature to drop because we've been
waiting for a sort of mac like
real multitasking experience on the ipad
so stage manager comes along and it is
technically a multitasking ui but the
more i use it the more i can sort of
crystallize this theory in my head which
is that
apple doesn't seem to want the ipad to
do
anything
the same way the mac does it now this
goes back a long way you know when the
ipad first came out it was more or less
a gigantic iphone but it's slowly gotten
more and more powerful in front of our
eyes until this point we have a thousand
dollar ipad pro with a 13 inch mini led
display and a whole m1 chip inside the
exact same chip that's in some of the
most popular computers that they make
but the ipad software has stayed
remarkably
consistent which is a nice way of saying
it hasn't advanced quite at the same
rate as this hardware so a lot of people
have big ipad dreams of wanting this to
be their only computer and have it be
just as capable as any other computer
but it hasn't been and that's been the
biggest knock on the ipad for a while
now sure we've gotten some stuff we have
widgets on the home screen since ipad os
15 we have our split screen apps we have
our slide over apps and all this stuff
but again you'll notice
that they specifically don't do anything
here the same way they would on a mac
they always want to find
a new
ipad way of doing it like when the ipad
first got a trackpad and mouse support
that was a big deal we were waiting for
that but instead of a normal mouse we
got this unique circle pointer thing
that floats between possible touch
targets very much the ipad way you might
remember when i asked craig federighi
why there wasn't a dedicated weather app
and calculator app on the ipad this was
his answer the ipad still does not have
a default weather and calculator app and
they want to know why
you know there's some things that we
we have not done because
we to do it we would want to do
something really distinctly
great in that space and uh i think it's
obviously easy to create a calculator
app uh but creating one that feels like
wow this is this is this is the greatest
ipad calculator app that it felt like i
think we we we want to do it when we can
do it really really well and and we we
honestly have just uh
uh
haven't gotten around to doing it great
so uh that that day that day may come
but uh
and you know whether it be easy enough
to scale up our additional our existing
weather app but we feel like what would
a great weather app for ipad be like
let's let's do that before we do it i
suppose that makes perfect sense but
listening back to that two years later
it sounds even more like
we haven't really gotten around to doing
it the ipad way yet even the headline on
apple's website for ipad os 16
incredibly capable unmistakably ipad so
when it comes to multitasking this is
like the last big hurdle on the ipad's
way to finally feeling like it's a real
computer we all know what we expect
multitasking to look like on a normal
computer like a mac but in accordance
with my theory and this i can't prove it
but this is just my theory is
apple doesn't ever want the ipad's
multitasking to look or feel or work
like it does
on a mac
they've got to find
a
ipad way of doing this now to throw a
wrench in my theory this is also coming
to the mac in the latest version but the
latest feature here is called stage
manager and uh it's not
bad it's just an inherently
new
different way of doing multitasking on a
touch screen or on a monitor like this
and it's just another thing you're gonna
have to learn to get the most out of
this thing so basically what it looks
like is you enable it in the settings
then toggle it on in control center once
you do you can open up an app to bring
it on stage and then off to the left
here you have your recent apps that are
off offstage so you're on stage app it's
a window it isn't quite full screen and
so you can drag the corner and move it
around and you can see that there's a
bunch of slightly different
predetermined window sizes it's not
perfectly fluid it's just a bunch of
sizes that apple picked and then you can
bring other apps from off stage to be on
stage at the same time so now this is
officially the first time you can have
more than one windowed app open at the
same time on the ipad and again you can
mess with the sizes you can group apps
together and then you can bring them on
or off stage at will so it is still
definitely very much not the same thing
as multiple windows open on a computer
with the little buttons in the corner
and then fully fluid window sizes and
all the stuff but it is running
simultaneous things at once and it is
multitasking and it is the ipad way you
can have up to four apps on a stage at
once which can look kind of ridiculous
and probably even more so on a smaller
ipad but then you can move a whole pile
of apps off stage by switching to
something else and then bring all four
of them back on at once it's just
technically a lot happening
simultaneously and then if you connect
the ipad to an external display finally
finally the ipad doesn't just mirror
anymore but it actually treats it like a
second display to extend onto and lets
you have up to four more piles to the
side on stage manager so you can really
multitask to your heart's content on a
large display where it doesn't feel as
crowded and you can have a ton of
processes happening at once it's
impressive but it's not perfect there
are already some pretty well documented
downsides the first one just being that
it's not very widely available literally
only m1 ipads will support this so
resource intensive that it uses memory
swaps so that's not very many ipads
right now but more importantly
i still think this is a little bit
complicated and not the most intuitive
thing in the world now this isn't the
end of the world for a ipad power user
who's just like yeah bring on the new ui
and stuff i'll learn it no problem but
are you also going to remember that if
you open an app that's already in
another group it will open that whole
group so you have to manually drag the
app out into another group if you want
to work in a different set of apps or
what about that you can't make it
automatically open apps maximize so you
have to drag them to cover the whole
display or hit the dots at the top and
hit zoom every time to bring them to
full screen or what about the fact that
there are iphone size apps still like
whatever the hell instagram is still
doing hence they don't resize at all and
they seem to mess with the whole
multitasking thing since you can't seem
to choose where it goes either and also
the fact that this feels like about the
fifth different way to multitask on an
ipad that's buried behind some slightly
obscure gestures and is off by default
there are still the three dots at the
top of every window if stage manager
isn't on and that's how you still get
into split screen apps which again have
a set number of predetermined sizes and
that's also how you get into slide over
apps which are the tall skinny apps that
you get to by sliding over from the side
which by the way have an entire
multitasking carousel of their own you
also can't drag windows straight from an
ipad to another display so you got to
click the three dots then move to
display and then do that same thing
again if you want to move them back and
the ipad does not work with a secondary
display while its own screen is off so
like a laptop a computer might have
clamshell mode where you close it but
it's still plugged into a monitor you
can use with the ipad if this screen is
off so is everything it's connected to
plus don't forget about the keyboard
shortcuts if you have the magic keyboard
that goes along with the ipad a lot of
them are the same as they are on a mac
but there are some that are slightly
different
it's a lot so i feel like you probably
get what i'm saying the the state of the
ipad is fascinating apple's given us an
amazing piece of hardware and it's very
powerful and they've added a bunch of
features to try to take advantage of it
but now in their effort to do it the
ipad way every single time they're
walking a tightrope between two sides
where one side is amazing intuitive
powerful on the other side is a little
too complicated a little bit unintuitive
and hard to remember they're just
right down the middle for people who use
an ipad how do you use your ipad what do
you do
specifically on the ipad are you a one
full screen app at a time person you
just keep it propped up in a folio touch
screen all the time let me know in the
comments section below how you use
the ipad and until the next one i will
continue to be confused about the
what is a computer question
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace